that's a wild game but we had another
completely Wild game Josiah first of all
congratulations big victory for your
first victory at the Juniors competition
first time you were actually
participating tell us a bit about your
story and uh your first time here yeah
and got the wild card in my last year of
Eligibility so I'm super stoked to be
here
um you know I've been on a good run
recently so feeling good about my form
and one half out of three not the best
start yesterday's game was pretty
devastating but uh glad to pick it up
again and what was a pretty wild game
let's discuss this game because
the advantage was going back and forth
every single move this position you
decided to go and play G5 yeah so it's
interesting here because I actually knew
F6 was the best move you did um okay
yeah and I saw this but uh I honestly
felt that uh to try to go for it yeah to
go for E5 because the problem is why
it's starting 95 depend on my Rook is
very annoying
um and so yeah I had calculated this but
I evaluated it as nearing a two result
game actually and I just really didn't
want that so I I had the feeling that I
needed to shake things up if you know I
was kind of pushing a little bit maybe
too hard but and you did
um he had an opportunity of potentially
taking on F5 maybe so if he takes an
angle Bishop 5 probably just the rookie
one really
just give up the pawn like this
for conversation yeah I had a feeling
that maybe this was dynamically terrible
for me but for some reason I was uh
it's not easy to assess yeah I can't
believe it's plus three take and Rook B6
something like that not easy to assess
H4 makes a lot of sense at least
visually and you found this idea very
nice idea of giving up a couple of
people yeah I was very happy with my my
find here
oh wow and then this moved to ga
which allows Knight takes F4 as well and
that was also nice so now I have four I
found Bishop G4 and then here really yes
this was the big one okay and I thought
25 oh then Queen yeah yeah no because I
had calculated Bishop takes F4 which
looks like it wins a piece but now I go
Queen uh I was planning H5 because he
can't take on C7 because I think I made
him yeah but wow and also this is not
easy to see
um and not easy to assess after F3 yeah
no I in this moment I was really holding
my breath like before all these
sacrifices because there's like five
different ways you can sacrifice exactly
yeah yeah okay I completely forgot about
Queen except for us we thought that this
would be yeah so here I thought Bishop
G4 challenge three oh
and
yeah no I thought after Bishop G4 he was
forced to play like 91 and then I was
gonna play Bishop G5 and I'm pretty sure
that this uh yeah that this is this is
good this is good for you man I miss a
lot of things then wild position
nonetheless not easy to calculate
everything
um but
we were kind of getting lost here we had
no idea how to assess yeah I mean
stopped using the engine and we're like
okay what in the world is happening yeah
after E5 I found my bishop h8 move was
or like a mission before and then okay
oh yeah Bishop ah is good yes yes this
was good yeah this transition was good
after that I think I actually made a
mistake and played Rook takes H6 I was a
bit hasty
B5 since they have been the best move
here I was thinking about that but then
I was worried about 94 and maybe I'd
take oh right Bishop 300. yeah
to be honest in this position he had
like six minutes left and he went out to
go to the bathroom and so I kind of
blitzed that right
yeah
that is definitely not something I can
and I knew his only move was Queen G3
um after Queen takes D5 no no after uh
after crook H6 yes so um yeah I was
pretty surprised when he came back from
bathroom in both Saudi seven so
maybe it worked what do you think he
missed perhaps I think what he missed
was Queen Queen H5 Queen h8 and I'm
defending the the E8 winning Square yeah
that's what so yeah assume this wall
yeah well maybe not the most precise but
still an important victory for you how
are you feeling about your chances what
are your Ambitions as the Wild Card
going into this event
um I mean I was looking for uh first
place I'm kind of uh I saw mishra's
interview that second to Tenth really
doesn't mean anything and I wouldn't say
I would go that far because I still have
GM to make
um and so you know every Point matters
but uh definitely you know it's only
three rounds in so I still believe I
have some decent chances to to take
first place if I play well so and
definitely a lot of holes I have to
patch up
well go get some rest and get ready for
tomorrow's match yes thank you Christian
uh questions okay I mean this was such a
complicated game I did not understand
anything what's happening there so many
sacrifices uh so maybe if he's still in
the studio it's just a question yeah
like how did you feel about the two
Pawns in the center like very worried or
were you just like I'm fine I'm gonna
survive with that piece there
well to be honest I was like worried
like the whole game until I made it him
but
I mean I kind of figured that with his
low time my Bishop pair especially here
I had a feeling that I had already taken
over
um the only point where I was really
worried was where all those sacrifices
were happening exactly yeah my intuition
was right that was bad but I guess I got
a little bit lucky
well done congratulations absolutely
congratulations indeed and I can't wait
for your book practical chess tips by
Josiah and make your moves when your
opponent went to the bathroom you know
pick up uh some time on the clock and
some strategy there exactly exactly
let's just uh jump to